the popularity of drones is soaring some
are now lifting off in swarms to perform
light shows in the night sky the
synchronized shooting star drones are
created by Intel Carter Evans shows us
the meticulous methods behind the
spectacular nighttime displays in the
California desert these so-called
shooting star drones turn the dark of
night into a canvas in the sky for
Coachella we've integrated different
animations a ferris wheel which is super
iconic for Coachella
Natalie chunks team at Intel has been in
the drone light show business for about
a year and a half their first aerial
achievement choreographing 100 drones to
music what's it like to be there when
one of these drone swarms takes off just
knots of pure excitement and joy I'm so
excited to see the drones take off and
just crossing my fingers now they can
fly as many as five hundred synchronize
drones to create each spectacle a team
of programmers engineers and animators
first build it on a computer and then we
upload the whole animation to the whole
fleet of drones so they're all following
a pre-planned pattern in the sky yep we
we know exactly what's going to happen
to our drones at every single frame in
seconds Chung's biggest stage yet was
Lady Gaga's halftime show during Super
Bowl 51 an audience of 111 million
watched 300 twinkling drones form a
giant aerial American flag drones are
taking Intel in a new direction the
company normally associated with micro
processors and semiconductors is about
to release its first commercial drone
the Falcon 8 plus Anil Nandor II is
Intel's vice president of new technology
you sometimes want to take pictures from
below and this gimbal is designed so you
can take 180 degree shots with a
high-res camera and other sensors this
drone can be deployed for a variety of
infrastructure inspections which can
help keep humans out of harm's way
the shooting star drones utilize the
same autopilot technology as the Falcon
II except there are no humans Manning a
remote control for each drone we have
this master computer that is the pilot
and that manages the whole fleet as we
call it intel worked closely with the
FAA to get special permission to launch
a drone swarm FAA regulations require
one pilot per drone and they can only
fly during daylight but Intel was
granted a waiver so one pilot with a
laptop can control multiple drones at
night but never directly above an
audience it's made out of foam and
plastic so it's really like it's really
like 2/3 of a pound the performance team
itself is surprisingly small we actually
need 2 people a pilot and a backup pilot
who's the backup for so it's just in
case the pilot can't make it for the
event each drone carries just a single
LED has over 4 billion color
combinations but one of the best parts
of the show is something the public
doesn't get to see I got to tell you
that's one of the coolest things shot of
all the drones coming it looks like a
tornado it's just so beautiful just to
see all these stars and drones just
falling down gracefully there's like
slight little buzz around you it's great
and if you're wondering what happens if
a drone should fail or lose
communication with the computer they use
a GPS to find their way home and land by
themselves for CBS this morning Carter
Evans Santa Clara California responsible
drone operation that's a good thing